that was awesome all right honey salt is
all about sweet savory and stylish gifts
for mom this weekend
rocky stop by the local restaurant to
preview their special mother's day
pop-up shop we are here at the beautiful
honey salt in summerlin where there is a
special
and very exclusive pop-up shop for mom
on friday from noon to four
and it's both inside the restaurant and
outside on the really nice patio as well
we've got food
and we've got local shopping too so
let's start with the food because we
have
the famous chef sterling buckley the
executive chef here of honey sauce so
let's talk about what we can eat you're
two kinds so we're gonna have a we're
gonna have a bake sale with some
really nice treats there and also we're
gonna have a sandwich bar and a bacon
grilled cheese will be one of the stars
there okay and also we're gonna have uh
our honey salt favorite dessert uh the
brookie
that's the signature dessert here right
yes it is yes it is and then
the french cottage bakery will be there
and then we have artisanal bread so yes
you can basically grocery shop as well
yes yes yes that's great i love it
sandwich to go there i love it all right
all right so we've got all this food
here for the bake shop and then
on the other side we've got local las
vegas owned
shopping to do let's talk about these
we have ross and snow you got the nice
sneakers over there
they have luxury sneakers not just any
kind of sneakers luxury and also
sterling did you know this is the first
luxury brand out of las vegas so this is
a very special brand yeah
and they're brand new so you'll be
getting kind of an exclusive
sneak peek at what they have to offer
and then of course the jewelry because
it's mom day that's right d berkeley
represent out here there's 14 carat
options there's diamond options
obviously some beautiful
bracelets as well and then instagramable
moments
because you're coming in here with your
mom shopping hanging out in this
beautiful restaurant there will be
a whole balloon wall yes will you be
taking some selfies
uh i take selfies anyway in between in
between bacon and give it to you bacon
well you guys can come down on friday
and all weekend oh tell us about brunch
i'm sorry oh yes we're fully committed
for sunday brunch but if you want to get
it popping early
for mama on saturday you feel free to
come by we open at 10 we close at 3 30
so you can bring mama early if you want
to celebrate early come hang out with
sterling
that's right all day all right friday
pop-up shop here at honey salt
friday noon to four come shop until
you're hungry
i'll send it back to you looks great
thank you rocky we'll check back in with
you during the 4pm newscast mercedes
over to you